overseas Russian police have arrested a
female suspect in a bombing that killed
a prominent supporter of Russia's war on
Ukraine the explosion blew up a cafe in
St Petersburg yesterday where that
blogger was giving a talk Holly Williams
is following this story from Ukraine
in Saint Petersburg yesterday vladen
tatarsky a well-known Russian military
blogger was presented with a statue
according to Russian State media a bomb
was hidden inside
and when it exploded it killed tatarsky
injuring at least 32 others he'd been a
vocal supporter of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine see if we've been saying in this
video last year we will kill everyone we
will rob everyone we need
Russia's pointed the finger at Ukraine
for the killing but a Ukrainian official
called it Russian domestic terrorism it
follows the murder of another prominent
supporter of the invasion Darian dugin
with a Car Bomb near Moscow last year
Russia's also under pressure from the
U.S over American journalist Evan
gershkovic arrested on spying charges
last week in a rare phone call with his
Russian counterpart Secretary of State
Anthony blinken urged Moscow to release
the reporter from The Wall Street
Journal Evan is an extremely
professional clever talented reporter
piota Sauer is a close friend of
goshkovic and a fellow journalist Russia
previously swapped U.S basketball star
Brittany Greiner for a convicted Russian
arms Trader Victor bout some suspect the
Kremlin also wants to trade gershkovich
for another Russian prisoner in the U.S
is it possible that he's essentially
being used as a as a hostage by the
Russian government yeah this is you know
just hostage taking
um this is we don't know why they're
doing it at this point but we know that
the Spy charges are completely absurd
Evan gershkovic is believed to be the
first American journalist arrested on
spying charges by Russia since the end
of the Cold War if he's convicted he
could face up to 20 years in a Russian
penal colony Vlad
Holly Williams in Ukraine thank you